we got a gigantomax amount of details
about pokemon sword and shield crown
tundra this morning
ea play on game pass got a release date
and so did torchlight 3.
i'm persia and this is your saves date
for tuesday september 29th
[Music]
today's pokemon stream was loaded with
details about sword and shield's
second expansion crown tundra in the
expansion
you can team up for dynamaxx adventures
with up to three other players
the raid dens will take you through a
series of dynamaxx battles
which also has many of the rare
legendaries on top of all of that
every single legendary pokemon in
history
is returning for crown tundra the
gallerian star tournament was also
revealed where you team up with trainers
and gem leaders
from the base game and isle of armor for
2v2 tournaments
we also got some new additions to the
gallerium pokedex and our first good
look
at gallerian slow king galarian slow
king is a dual poison psychic type much
like valerian slobro
the crown tundra expansion is releasing
on october 22nd
with new versions of pokemon sword and
shield that include the expansion pass
available on november 6th and before the
year is up you'll also be able to bring
your pokemon from pokemon go
to sword and shield through pokemon home
if you want
any more details on the live stream or
any of the announcements
then visit gamespot for more coverage
microsoft had previously announced that
ea play would be coming to game pass
this holiday but now we have an official
release date
as you might have guessed ea play will
be available on xbox game pass on
november 10th
right alongside the launch of the series
x and
s you will have to wait until december
to access ea play
on the pc version of game pass but it's
worth noting that the version of ea play
within game pass
is the basic tier so you won't get
access to all of ea's new releases
but you'll still be able to play games
from the basic library some of those
games include star wars jedi fallen
order
need for speed heat and more and to take
it even further
xbox's xcloud streaming service will let
you stream some of those games on
android devices so regardless this
partnership is still
a significant boost for game pass
the release dates don't stop there
torchlight 3
is coming to ps4 xbox one and pc on
october 13th
torchlight 3 was originally torchlight
frontiers during early access
but ended up being completely retooled
to be a proper sequel
now it's a four player online hack and
slash rpg
like the first two games there will be a
switch version coming later this year
but
no word yet on the next gen each version
of the game also
includes different pet companions
torchlight 3 is right around the corner
but if you want to check out the early
access version
it's still up now on pc that's your news
for today thanks for watching and don't
forget to reach your next safe state
here tomorrow
see you later
[Music]
you